[Music]
hello welcome to another episode what's
in the box
I'm Ted Theodore Logan man and I'm bill
S Preston Esquire anyway and everyone
that we're gonna look in the box that's
the only reason we're here the only
reason we're on this earth mr. Mitas has
a knife he's gonna put it to good use
oh yeah look at that cutting job sexy
sexy mmm well that wasn't very erotic at
all but sliced well okay Paul this is
the part of the show that matters the
most
what's in the box what's in the box we
got a lot of packing peanuts something
in here kinder get your joy for boys
finally they box joy for boys I have no
idea it's edible as what it is homeboy
you can eat this yes
oh so it's a toy you eat it and it's got
toys inside but you don't eat the toy
very important don't eat the toys fat
man knows how to find food at the bottom
of the box I'll tell you that much I see
Iron Man well this one's got Disney
Princess version two for girls well we
can't eat that her girls these are for
boys so we could totally eat these all
right and the ones that we can't even
just whip around the room these look
pretty amazing this is called kinder joy
there's two parts to it and this has a
spoon so you use this spoon I think on
whatever's inside here there's a spoon
comes off here and then this side has
the toilet oh oh look at this
oh that looks like Swedish meatballs mom
can i Swedish meatballs with a fairy in
it now the thing about these kinder joy
you see it's a toy separate from your
food
Kinder Surprise eggs they're called
that's the one that has candy and then
there's a toy inside like I've been over
season I've seen them the u.s.
regulations ban putting non-food objects
inside food so they're outlawed here you
go YouTube watch people open them and
it's got Billy and 5 billion views well
let's keep up I'm just saying like
everything you've done in life every
piece of media you've ever made put
together will never reach now 1 billion
views let alone five people love to
watch
people open stuff up and I would prefer
the version where you could eat it and
then spit the toy out that be amazing
really and you're spitting this thing
out see that makes sense now when you
see these little pieces imagine you're
biting in the chocolate you're just
right now nothing makes sense about this
phenomenon this is gonna be one of those
things where in a couple of years people
like Norma we were so bored that we all
open kinder egg for a while remember
you're so bored we watched people
opening kinder eggs
that was before World War for this is
the Marvel version kids it says four
boys don't you listen home girls you can
like spider-man - look at this dude
finally now some recognize how I can
characters man there's a little version
of Iron Man but what does he do - try
open just something snaps dude oh and
then I see you're saying is the ball hit
his dome comes open oh there's numbers
oh you can play them together with other
characters Oh
when Captain America throws his mighty
shield put his head on him body okay we
got a turn may be numbered shooting
number I'm a number two to number two or
something you gotta go head to head
right aha
and now you'd connect this dude like
this aha now now you're having fun oh
that's weird
no fun right no not at all
now wait a second that's a cute kangaroo
oh all right you know I take back
everything I said this might yeah you
ain't kidding this is worth having it I
give this to my kid she's gonna think of
my superhero
look it looks like it's a pencil holder
or something like hey yeah I can hang on
pencils oh yes I can show you the world
I mean clears jasmine though with no
legs is creepy
I guess you're just snapping together
address yes this is the fun part
building I can't believe like that was
it that was they were you put her dress
on like hey kids isn't that fun and now
you're done now put it down and don't
touch it again lest you break it but
still is good looking for green look
look oh okay
it softens you it's good for you alright
I like it I could do earrings for these
alright this is something I got for you
bro he gave me the bracelet this is my
heart I'd give it to you
well you gave me a bracelet do I wasn't
that awkward
look at this do I see awkward that's
right
Thor there you go see that would be fun
and then it would be cold like why would
this be fun if you opened them up yeah
and you got Thor's and Captain America's
and spider-man's but one of these lucky
where is it going I was doing and you
are like Kenny put his dick in ER you
ruin Disney I want to say dick I'll just
say hammer you know that's what he calls
it when you think door is right as
ladies like come here baby
you want to see my hammer bulging muse
this is why nobody that calling Joss
Whedon not you to make those movies like
hey what if we did see to where Thor
showed us we'd like there's the door get
the [ __ ] out look at this squirrel man
good time to be in half with this school
[Music]
again I'm keeping this man my kids gonna
like this milk of high quality is the
golden rules of Kinder Joey you gotta
have high quality milk you can't have
any colorings with you can't be any
preservatives God have selected raw
materials I don't even know what that
means
fifth on their list is production
process with high hygiene standards see
well that's weird when somebody tells
you like I swear we make clean food look
like melting it's melty burn just eat
one no well yeah but I'm gonna do a back
I got tired that tastes like it was made
in a hygienic ly clean place look at
this oh no that's cool now that's a ball
brother but we got 9 of them so it's not
that cool but it bounces - no way oh
that's good times kids this is good
times watch this bro snow it's kind of
like a boomerang
oh yeah that's wicked let's play a game
where you shoot and I try to hit it with
my ball alright guys ready the best toy
ever yeah alright fun with my fun
alright and that's the point of
childhood kids before
[Music]
okay we got one more box our I'm kinder
eggs
hello I mean you know I know a lot of
people online I like you blow it all
your movies blow I understand they do
but that doesn't change the fact that
kinder eggs kind of blow in my
estimation the ones that you can eat
that have toys in them that you're
spitting out that's the one I want the
choking hazard version that's the one I
want
what's this this is fun surprise in
every chocolate yes now how come this is
legal this is legal but the other
exactly GLE this is an egg with a toy in
it chocolate treasure front surprise in
every toy their mascot is a dragon
sitting on the truck yes there's an
American guy who made his knockoff
version of these he found a way around a
government role he puts the eggs in the
chocolate oh look at that that's why
it's got the egg inside like a play-doh
egg it's very smart welcome
well you're not very talkative I'd like
at the toy oh snap karate rhino karate
always this is my baby part the hollowed
out you can use this as a dessert food
you go to kitchen put ice cream in it
yeah you can be like I can't hear you I
can't hear you have like you can
definitely definitely choke your ball
bags in there that's times dude
seriously I joined up getting stress out
this is the best part I saw getting the
toy in this instance is stickers oh
there's a cat man whoa hockey duck oh my
god hockey penguin CDs have much better
toys bro these are incredible two
penguins that much got a team the best
part is the smashy smashy go ahead okay
manifest give it a Deusen no but did you
see how it split the edges
you've heard over the egg in a different
way than his all look at this and inside
it's a top dude yeah work it ready yeah
[Music]
way better toys than the kinder joy I'll
say that right now I've got hours of
enjoyment from this stuff still going by
American this is like Inception right
here man sooner or later we're gonna run
follow me I was stronger who's you
trying to break yeah it's trying to
bring home that's true that's true
except I lose the toy every time I can
open it with my mouth like the girl of
Twin Peaks like time the cherry stem
[Music]
come on this shouldn't even count as a
[ __ ] toy look yeah it's ridiculous
it's a paper toy this is like opening up
a crackerjack toy surprise in finding a
mini Bible yeah that's the last one bro
oh and the last is playing cards bro
daddy you play a little game of I'm
actually charmed by this I play a lot of
52 rummy man I play bring this home to
my wife and be like you want to play
cards with little cards and she'd be
like is that where we are in our
marriage you think that's interesting or
exciting don't you [ __ ] me like a man
I'm like well I I just I care I got a
little plate I wonder if there's 52
there is no Joker's I can tell you like
this is the most amusing thing out of
all this ground like somebody made a
deck of cards so small they fit in a
candy egg you're not allowed to eat and
here's a couple Joker's that's for you
living a bet for the toys and stuff I'm
like I bring you two penguins
oh here's a hockey duck I see you're
trying I can't even get a shuffle going
man I got you do it like in Vegas where
they do a wash how much you think these
are I would say 99 cents right they're a
dollar a piece man you know you got a
kid or maybe you don't got a kid maybe
an adult you're like I of a short
attention span you buy it for a buck you
get some crap you move on with your life
there's a feeling
accomplishment and opening Matak I'll be
honest with you but I still don't
understand why this is popular online
like you know be more interesting
opening a real leg studying the old
finding out how life how chicken comes
from that and stuff but instead this
although that tops pretty cool I would
say my favorite prize I saw inside of
these probably the you know I gotta go
with hockey duck that's over hockey
penguin that's I'm probably gonna take
those on I like hockey what was your
favorite thing I do like the karate
Rhino let these little toys are fun but
again I'm gonna go comics and I would
say what other food could you put toys
in that would be more interesting toy
scream and so what you got is big
calling yeah you lick it around you're
right in the middle of it there's a
little toy or something in there I was
thinking something more like mashed
potatoes then you get smushed mashed
potatoes down and get the toy right
could you imagine me are you - potatoes
and suddenly like it's a 9 um figure
thanks mom true best you might need it
well I would that's it ladies and
gentlemen we opened up a bunch of food
this week and found crap toys inside of
it this is a trend that's sweeping the
Internet man so when you look for your
kids and you're like is he in his room
masturbating again no he's not he's
watching videos of people opening up
chocolate eggs and look at little toys I
promise you you want to see us open up
other things let us know don't be shy go
screen junkies a Twitter account go
their Facebook page email them tell us
tell them and they'll tell us in return
what do you want to see us open right
here man on what's in the box but until
next week we're done open and crap
that's the most sugar I've had in like a
year and right now I'm like until next
week man I'm Kevin Smith join us next
week right here and we'll find out
what's in the box what's in the box
[Music]
you